we're talking about not just who gets to
hold one house of Congress we're talking
about what people are going to do with
that political power and the Democrats
have abused their political power to use
just one example
they locked kids at home for absolutely
no reason for the better part of three
years and even Liberals are starting to
see this sunny Hosten on The View who is
wrong about almost everything
Sunny Hosten just pointed out you know
guys should we
did we kind of
we kind of harm the kids for a couple
years over this pandemic which is people
say it's totally over but there are like
a thousand people dying from it still
every day I'm a little nervous
because teens are in a lot of trouble
there's a mental health crisis I've seen
it in my children they're in trouble now
because they don't know how to speak to
each other and they were you know out of
school and they were homebound
good I'm glad better late than never
you're you're starting to get it maybe
when kids face statistically not a whole
lot of health risk pretty much like
nothing from this virus and then you
lock them out of school because the
teacher unions want a paid vacation and
then you Coop them up in their home
their development will be slowed their
education broadly will be slowed
yeah that's true their socialization
will be slowed their anxiety their
stress even their suicidality will
increase yeah that's all true
maybe that was a bad thing to do
there's this weird switch that has
happened which is
for many many years
the sign of a demagogue
was the sort of person who would say
well somebody please think of the
children you think of the church lady in
the Simpsons won't somebody please think
of the children and that that was
A Fairly reliable sign of a demagogue
however that was back in a Time
when people thought of the children
I was back in a time when people really
cared about the children tried to do
what was in their best interest tried to
pursue the common good and didn't only
pursue their own selfish interests now
nobody is thinking of the children now
it's kind of flipped and when someone
says want somebody please think of the
children they're expressing a legitimate
concern
think about what we're doing to children
we're locking them out of school
we're chopping flesh off of their
forearms and on their legs to create
fake genitals we're castrating them at
very very young ages because we're
indulging that a boy can be a girl and a
girl can be a boy and we're doing that
to appease the sexual fetishes of very
adults we've redefined marriage so that
now we are creating children for the
express purpose of denying them their
mother or their father all to appease
the disordered and selfish desires of
adults we are really screwing over the
kids we we really really are and this is
a relatively new phenomenon
and it is no longer the sign of a
demagogue to say when somebody please
think of the children
the conservatives have said it recently
and now even liberals like Sunny Hosten
on The View are saying uh hey you know
maybe those conservatives have a point
maybe
like is anybody thinking of the children
maybe we should maybe that would be a
good idea the lack of immigration
enforcement is not a bug in our system
it is a feature of the system
there are many things
that are ostensibly problems or
challenges or accidents in our political
order that are in fact quite intentional
a great example of this
black lives matter
Claremont Institute just did a study
this was the Claremont center for the
American way of life
love the Claremont Institute love the
Claremont Review of Books Claremont did
a study of how much money BLM has raked
in do you know how much money these guys
have made just from corporations I'm not
talking about Grassroots money activists
fight the man on the street no from just
regular
establishment corporations
BLM has raised
82.9 billion dollars
billion with a B
as a point of reference says Claremont
82.9 billion dollars is more than the
GDP of 46 African countries
that's how powerful BLM is
to put it in perspective last year the
Ford Motor Company's profits were 23
billion dollars
you could fit
three
coming up on four Ford Motor companies
within the the
accounting books
for money that BLM has made just from
corporations
and this number 82.9 billion this
includes more than 123 million dollars
to BLM parent organizations directly and
obviously much much more to the
subsidiary BLM organizations just from
Corporate America which shows something
that
probably most of you understood from the
beginning but most Americans did not
understand from the beginning
which is that
BLM was never fighting the system
BLM is the system
it was never in opposition they
pretended they were in opposition we're
going to fight the cops we're gonna burn
down the courthouses we're going to
attack the economic system by looting a
bunch of sneaker stores and jewelry
stores
but then what would happen
the most powerful interests in the
country would bail them out
the current Vice President of the United
States bailed these people out of jail
bailed the criminals the rioters out of
jail staffers for Joe Biden bailed these
people out of jail
the district attorneys just wouldn't
prosecute a lot of them
maybe a slap on the wrist in many cases
just charges dismissed
because BLM is serving a purpose in the
political order the the government is
still somewhat constrained by
the Constitution to some degree by the
law to some degree by Optics to a larger
degree and by custom to some degree
so how does the government terrorize
political dissidents well the only way
to do it is through its
military Wing the only way to do it is
through its Terror Wing that would be
BLM
but BLM is not opposing the interests of
the establishment if it were that
establishment wouldn't be giving them
almost 83 billion dollars
it's the same thing with big Tech the
the government is constrained from
censoring its political dissonance
outright in many cases
we have a First Amendment the the
government doesn't want to go through
the whole rigmarole of fighting out
these cases in court so what do they do
they Outsource speech broadly to a
handful of corporations in Silicon
Valley they work very closely with those
corporations the FBI has regular
meetings with Executives at those
corporations talks about which people
the government doesn't really want to
hear from talks about which Stories the
government doesn't really want getting
out and then big Tech does the
censorship bidding for the government
so these platforms are not standing in
opposition to the government
to the system they're working in tandem
obviously same thing goes for the Press
the Press is not the brave fourth estate
where the Intrepid courageous
journalists speaking truth to power they
don't speak truth almost ever
not when it counts at least we saw this
just last week when there was a a
concerted effort by the press to libel
me which they did they eventually had to
back down because we called it out and
we mustered enough political pressure
from the right-wing media from
right-wing politicians from the right
wing Grassroots that they had to back
off a little bit but that's what they do
they're not the Intrepid fourth estate
they work on behalf of the system the
rest of the show continues now you don't
want to miss it become a member and use
code Knowles kwles at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
oh